shock and disbelief in Berlin after
several violent incidents at underground
metro stations the traces of the latest
are still clearly visible a homeless man
was asleep on this bench when a group of
men set him on fire a surveillance
camera captured the incident recording
the attackers as they fled the scene by
train authorities made the video public
within a few hours six of the seven
attackers came forward and the seventh
was arrested they are reportedly of
syrian and libyan origin aged between 15
and 21 their crime and the swift
identification of those responsible has
stoked the debate about increased video
surveillance in germany i think there
should be more video surveillance in
general as if you recite you to feel
more under surveillance I don't think
it's particularly efficient or
worthwhile as a preventive measure is on
us as it is if it's handled as in front
of shots Espinosa gospodin I am torn on
the one hand I don't want to be
monitored everywhere but on the other
hand I think it makes sense if it means
more crimes like this can be sold off
declared Vern mata Swanson many people
here in Berlin are concerned about
safety and feel that violent crimes are
on the increase but the fact still a
different story yeah I'm here as images
this is a question of whether people
feel safe there is a certain level of
anxiety zorb but if we look at the crime
figures we can see that the number of
robberies and violent crimes is actually
decreasing starting to work in
it's also clear that security cameras
cannot prevent crimes the man who were
set on fire did not suffer any injuries
but not because of the cameras ordinary
people rushed to his aid and helped push
out the fire